[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta sabíais que
existe un país llamado purundi antes de
haber hecho clic en este vídeo
seguramente muy pocos lo podáis Ubicar
en el mapa sin embargo burundi tiene el
dudoso honor de liderar un ranking es el
país más pobre del mundo pobre incluso
para los estándares africanos
[Música]
con una renta per cápita de 274 dólares
son pobres incluso para los estándares
africanos para que os hagáis una idea
Liberia que no es precisamente
Luxemburgo les triplica en renta per
cápita y las perspectivas de futuro son
aún peores y diréis Pero por qué os
Hablamos hoy de burundi Pues porque
justo al lado de burundi está este otro
país Ruanda
[Música]
Ruanda y burundi son dos países primos
hermanos ambos países fueron colonias
belgas de hecho eran la misma Colonia
podríamos decir que fueron el mismo país
hoy en día ambos países son dictaduras
sin embargo la situación de Ruanda es
muy distinta por supuesto ruando sigue
siendo un país pobre ahora bien las
cosas en este país están cambiando y
mucho simplemente fijaos en estas dos
fotos
a la izquierda podéis ver buyumbura la
capital de burundi como veis es un
panorama desolador a la derecha tenéis
sin embargo kigali la capital de Ruanda
por supuesto sigue siendo una ciudad
pobre pero ya se empiezan a ver
rascacielos modernos hoteles y alguna
que otra infraestructura y no solamente
hablamos de fotos cuando vamos a los
números la realidad de ambos países no
podía ser más distinta atentos a esta
gráfica
[Música]
como veis ambos países eran Igualmente
pobres en los años 60 sin embargo Ruanda
está creciendo como la espuma mientras
que burundi parecía anclada en la
miseria y la pregunta es por qué por qué
burundi sigue siendo el país más pobre
del mundo y por qué su vecina Ruanda
crece muchísimo más rápido que están
haciendo distinto hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos
a hablar de cómo navegar por internet de
forma segura y sin fronteras como podéis
ver páginas de internet de burundi o de
Ruanda o de cualquier otro país de China
de Estados Unidos sin ninguna
restricción geográfica Cómo podemos
hacer todo eso sin que nos entren un
montón de hackers a nuestro móvil o a
nuestro ordenador
Exacto utilizando una VPN y cuál es la
VPN favorita de visualpolitik Exacto
surfshark VPN creedme el tema de la
ciberseguridad se lo toma muy pero que
muy en serio por ejemplo surfshark tiene
una herramienta que se llama cleanweb
que bloquea todos esos popups de
propaganda por donde se cuelan un montón
de bo de cookies que francamente no
queremos tener en nuestros dispositivos
pues y todo esto fuera poco con una
única cuenta de surfshark VPN podré
registrar todos los dispositivos que
queráis queréis navegar con seguridad
desde el teléfono móvil desde la tablet
del ordenador la Smart TV pues no
importa podéis hacer todo eso con una
única cuenta de surfshark VPN Y por
supuesto tenemos una oferta muy especial
para todos vosotros que seguís
visualpolitik básicamente si utilizáis
el código politic terminado en K podréis
disfrutar de 1,83% de descuento más tres
meses extra totalmente gratuitos tenéis
todos los enlaces en la descripción no
esperéis más y descargaos ya la
aplicación y ahora sí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
la guerra olvidada
Y si os dijera que se pueden crear razas
desde una oficina del gobierno es decir
que un burócrata puede crear divisiones
raciales Donde antes existía una
sociedad relativamente homogénea suena
distópico verdad incluso maquiavélico
pues lo cierto Es que esto es lo que
hicieron los colonos belgas en lo que
llamaron el territorio Ruanda urundi
muchos historiadores afirman que esta
zona de África era una de las más
homogéneas desde el punto de vista
étnico sin embargo los colonos belgas
decidieron crear una división artificial
cutus por un lado y tutsis por el otro
de repente todos los colonizados tenían
que llevar una tarjeta de identidad que
mostraba a qué grupo exactamente
pertenecían a los tutsis que era La
minoría se les dieron los mejores
empleos y a los hutus que eran la
mayoría se les dio los peores trabajos
conclusión Pues que poco a poco
comenzaron las tensiones étnicas
en el año 1962 Ruanda aúnndi se
independizó de Bélgica y se convirtieron
en los dos estados que ahora conocemos
Ruanda por un lado y burundi por el otro
en principio parecen buenas noticias
verdad los países que logran su libertad
y su soberanía a partir de ahora
empezaría el cuento de hadas verdad pues
nada más lejos de la realidad los tutsis
se quedaron con el gobierno de burundi
esto generó protestas por parte de los
juntus y como respuesta el gobierno
tutsi asesino entre 100.000 y 200.000
hotus en Ruanda fue al revés aquí fueron
los hutus quienes dieron un golpe de
estado en el año 1973 y desde entonces
miles de tutsis fueron masacrados o
expulsados del país sin embargo el
auténtico genocidio y bien digo
genocidio llegó en los años 90 y diréis
cuál fue el evento que desató toda la
masacre pues atentos a esta noticia los
presidentes de Ruanda y burundi mueren
al ser atacado el avión en que viajaban
el 6 de abril de 1994 los presidentes de
Ruanda y burundi viajaban en un avión
cuando estaban a punto de pensar en la
capital de Ruanda quigalli un misil
derribó la aeronave y así es como ambos
países entraron en dos guerras civiles
distintas en Ruanda la radio del
gobierno dirigida por los sutus empezó a
difundir mensajes como éste
sí
nunca nunca
en solo 100 días los jutos masacraron al
11% de la población habéis oído bien el
genocidio ruandés es uno de los
episodios más salvajes y a la vez más
desconocidos de la historia moderna no
solo hablamos de un ejército matando a
gente también fueron los propios civiles
armados con machetes quienes salieron a
la calle a matar a sus vecinos de las
formas más salvajes que os podáis
imaginar Esto es lo que ocurrió en
Ruanda pero en burundi llevaban ya
décadas de guerra civil en los años 70
en los tutsis habían exterminado a
cientos de miles de jotos en los años 90
las tornas cambiaron En otras palabras
que ambos países vivieron una guerra
racial de características muy similares
sin embargo ahora es cuando viene la
gran diferencia en Ruanda los refugiados
tutsis que lograron escapar del país se
organizaron en campos de refugiados y
aquí es cuando entra en escena este
señor que veis en pantalla
Paul kagame venció a los genocidas y se
convirtió en presidente de Ruanda en el
año 2000 hoy en día sigue siendo el
presidente y no me malinterpretéis
Ruanda está lejos de ser una democracia
Pero de eso vamos a hablar más adelante
el caso de burundi es muy distinto en
este caso la guerra civil no terminó
hasta el año 2003 y en burundi el
protagonista de la historia fue este
otro señor que también veis en pantalla
hablamos de Pierre incununciza
presidente de burundi desde 2005 hasta
2020 Y diréis qué ha pasado en estos
países desde entonces pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
un país sin motocicletas
vamos a decirlo claro la geografía no
está del lado de burundi de entrada a
este país no tiene ningún recurso
natural además tampoco tiene salida al
mar por lo que no pueden tener puertos
para exportar nada sin embargo en el año
2000 llegaba una buena noticia a este
país
el acuerdo de arusa afirmado en 2000
ofrece una nueva promesa democrática
arreglos institucionales inclusivos y
una mayor rendición de cuentas de las
élites políticas por lo tanto el proceso
de paz de burundi fue ampliamente
celebrado por observadores externos este
acuerdo abrió el camino a las elecciones
multipartidistas A diferencia de Ruanda
burundi parecía recibir la democracia
con los brazos abiertos y en el año 2005
es donde entra en escena nuestro
personaje tierra incuroncita este hombre
pertenecía a la etnia juto pero quería
dejar a un lado todas las identidades y
los conflictos raciales de hecho llegó
el poder con este mensaje la sangre
derramada los últimos 12 años es mucha y
suficiente pero como ya hemos visto una
y otra vez en visualpolitik una cosa es
lo que los políticos dicen y otra muy
distinta a lo que hacen desde el año
2005 burundi está lejos muy lejos pero
extremadamente lejos de ser una
democracia pero que os hagáis una idea
es uno de esos países donde los
observadores Internacionales de la ONU y
de las instituciones internacionales
tienen que ir con lo que se llama
unminder es decir una persona del
gobierno que se encarga de ser algo así
como su sombra de esta forma ningún
observador puede observar nada que el
gobierno no quiera mostrar en cualquier
caso burundi ni siquiera se esfuerza ya
en dar muestras de ser una democracia
atentos a esta noticia del año 2015 el
presidente de burundi encisa gana un
polémico tercer mandato el presidente
anunció que se quedaría en el poder a
pesar de los límites constitucionales
pero no solo eso se hizo por clamar guía
supremo eterno habéis oído bien os lo
repito guía supremo eterno y como os
podéis imaginar tras este auto
nombramiento las prote no se hicieron
esperar y como también os podéis
imaginar el guía supremo eterno que
considera que los Derechos Humanos son
opcionales las reprimió con toda lasaña
más de 400.000 refugiados tuvieron que
abandonar el país y a todo esto y que
sumarle los miles de ejecutados y
desaparecidos que por supuesto no se
pueden contar porque han llegado a
cerrar la Oficina de derechos humanos de
la ONU de hecho burundi ha sido el
primer país del mundo en abandonar la
Corte Penal Internacional Y diréis por
qué Pues porque quería ir Investigar los
presuntos crímenes cometidos entre 2015
y 2017 por el líder supremo eterno sin
embargo de todas las medidas represivas
que han puesto en este país la más
llamativa es la prohibición de las
motocicletas así tal cual como lois ir
en motocicleta es uno de los peores
delitos que se pueden cometer en burundi
y diréis Pero por qué Pues porque dicen
atentos que la gente que va en
motocicletas podría estar conspirando
pero la guinda del pastel del guía
supremo eterno es esta noticia
funcionarios en la cárcel después de que
el líder de burundi fuera fuertemente
marcado en un partido de fútbol así como
lo escucháis quizás se encontraba
jugando un partido de fútbol en un
equipo que intentad poner caras de
sorprendidos vale además es el dueño es
el dueño del equipo y decidió mandar a
la cárcel a dos personas en un partido
de fútbol porque hicieron faltas y este
es solo un ejemplo Lo cierto es que las
historias de este presidente no se nos
ocurriría ni a los guionistas de
visualpolitik Finalmente y para sorpresa
de muchos en el año 2019 anunció que no
buscaría su reelección y se postuló su
sucesor elegido evaristein Daisy mille
quien es Por cierto el actual presidente
incununciza murió Al poco tiempo de un
paro cardíaco y se hicieron nuevas
elecciones pero parece que las cosas no
han cambiado para nada esta es la
democracia estilo
burón dice celebra unas elecciones
marcadas por la violencia y el
coronavirus dicho de otra forma que no
solo Hablamos de una dictadura salvaje
además estamos hablando de una dictadura
totalmente arbitraria y sobre todo
ultraviolenta y os preguntaréis que
clase de economía puede desarrollarse en
un país así
Pues creo que no os vais a sorprender
ninguno atentos a esta gráfica
aquí podéis ver las exportaciones de
burundi como porcentaje de su producto
interior bruto como veis no solo son
mucho más bajas que la media de todo
África subsahariana es que además la
tendencia es a peor como os podéis
imaginar un país sin recursos naturales
como burundi que necesita evidentemente
inversión extranjera es decir gente
dispuesta a invertir dinero para
construir fábricas de algún tipo el
problema quién invertiría en un país
como burundi de entrada tienen tres
impedimentos esenciales burocracia en
fronteras nula seguridad jurídica y
física y corrupción por ejemplo existen
Checkpoints en todas partes y en todas
ellas te piden una mordida eso significa
que si no tiene salida al mar enviar
cualquier mercancía al puerto más
cercano puede suponer un auténtico
fortunón
es el país más densamente poblado de
África y el crecimiento demográfico es
bestial a esto le suma es un débil
crecimiento económico y da como
resultado Un aumento continuó en su tasa
de pobreza que se espera alcance cerca
del 87% considerando un umbral de 1,90
dólares al día su pib per cápita es el
último de todo el mundo y para darnos
cuenta de su pobre desarrollo se estima
que únicamente el 12% de sus calles
están pavimentadas
pero esperad un momento porque desde
occidente sí que se intentan poner toda
clase de ayudas para intentar sacar este
país de la pobreza Y diréis cómo Pues
con medidas como esta urundi salud a la
decisión de la Unión Europea de levantar
las sanciones contra el país después de
seis años la Unión Europea y Estados
Unidos han decidido hacer la vista gorda
con la dictadura de burundi y han
levantado las sanciones económicas La
pregunta es cambiará esto algo pues lo
cierto Es que es muy difícil que burundi
puede llegar a tener algo que exportar a
Estados Unidos O a la Unión Europea o a
cualquier otro país cuando es que no
tienen nada que exportar y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos por un día es
un país condenado es imposible que un
país en esta zona marcado por los
genocidios y encima sin recursos
naturales pueda salir de la pobreza
verdad pues atentos porque ahora vamos a
mostrar la otra cara de la moneda Vamos
a viajar a Ruanda
[Música]
la Singapur africana
mientras que en burundian prohibido las
motocicletas Ruanda es curiosamente el
primer país de la zona que ha llegado a
desarrollar su propio modelo de
motocicleta por supuesto no os esperéis
una moto de carreras de último modelo
Pero al menos han llegado al nivel de
desarrollo suficiente como para poder
crear sus propias motos puede parecernos
abogada pero pensada en toda la cadena
de valor que hace falta para poder
fabricar algo tan complejo como una moto
hablamos de montones de empresas
proveedoras talleres y mano de obrar
relativamente cualificada Ruanda ha
llegado a tener todo eso dicho de otra
forma que sin tener grandes recursos
naturales han sido capaces de
desarrollar productos industriales y
diréis pero que han hecho también en
este país Quién ha hecho en Ruanda que
no se haya hecho en burundi pues vamos a
repasar su historia reciente Aunque Por
cierto si queréis más detalles tenemos
un vídeo en visualpolitik donde lo
tratamos con detalle como decíamos hace
unos minutos Ruanda salió del genocidio
con Paul kagame por supuesto Paul kagame
no aspira a ser un presidente
democrático ni muchísimo menos lleva 22
años en el poder y no parece que vaya a
dejarlo pronto sin embargo su modelo de
gobierno tiene un referente muy claro
Singapur
es decir que si hablamos de Derechos
Humanos Lo más seguro es que salga
reprobado Pero si hablamos de economía
nos damos cuenta de que sabe muy bien lo
que hace su forma de evitar futuros
genocidios es eliminando la libertad de
expresión para que no haya racismo es
decir en Ruanda la corrección política
es obligatoria después de lo que vimos
con la radio ruandesa podemos ver que en
este país saben las consecuencias de lo
que es el discurso del odio conclusión
Ruanda al igual que Singapur tiene
terminantemente prohibido hacer el más
mínimo comentario o chiste racista ni
siquiera se pueden hacer alusiones a los
hutus y a los tutsis por supuesto el
gobierno de kagame es tan represor como
cualquier dictadura ahora bien Es mucho
menos arbitrario por ejemplo en un
estudio realizado por transparencia
internacional de 180 países Ruanda se
encuentra en la posición 51 en lo que
corrupción respecta mientras que burundi
se encuentra en el lugar 165 Esta es
otra razón más para entender el fracaso
por ejemplo en Ruanda y represión
política Por supuesto que la hay pero no
es algo diferente a lo que podamos
encontrar en el resto del continente
aquí al menos el gobierno ha conseguido
garantizar la seguridad hoy en día que
está considerada como una de las
ciudades más seguras de toda África
subsahariana es difícil encontrar
estadísticas fiables pero hay algo que
no miente el turismo atentos a esta
gráfica
por ejemplo ya hay cadenas de hoteles
internacionales que han abierto enormes
complejos en kigali desde Marriott hasta
radisson pero no solo hablamos de
turismo también han llegado a
desarrollar comercio e incluso servicios
financieros para que os hagáis una idea
según el ranking business del Banco
Mundial Ruanda es el país de África más
favorable para hacer negocios y lo
sitúan por encima de países como España
o Japón y de hecho según el Banco
Mundial tienen la segunda legislación
que mejor protege los registros de la
propiedad y la tercera que mejor protege
el acceso al crédito incluso ya están
empezando a desarrollar un pequeño
sector tecnológico y tiene ya sus
pequeñas gigantes Como por ejemplo la
cervecera brahirma Por supuesto que hay
sospechas de que los datos estadísticos
que aporta Ruanda no son del todo
verídicos De hecho en los últimos dos
años la inversión extranjera ha caído en
picado pero hay algo indudable tigali es
hoy una ciudad completamente distinta a
lo que vimos en los telediarios en los
años 90 y las cifras macroeconómicas con
todo el maquillaje que tienen dibujan
una diferencia brutal vamos a volver a
esta gráfica
como veis burundi tiene casi cuatro
veces menos que el pib de Ruanda con
Prácticamente la misma población y una
historia una historia triste compartida
ambos tomaron Dos caminos distintos y la
diferencia hoy en día no podía ser más
palpable En otras palabras hay una
conclusión muy clara que podemos sacar
de esta comparación la política y las
instituciones importan
independientemente de la historia o de
los recursos naturales las instituciones
políticas son el principal factor que
marca la diferencia entre esto
y esto
pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que es posible hacer compatible
el desarrollo de un país como Ruanda con
la democracia y los Derechos Humanos Qué
elecciones puede aprender burundi del
caso ruandés hasta qué punto Ruanda
puedes de verdad llegar a salir de la
pobreza y convertirse en un país de
clase media lo llegaremos a ver en esta
década O tal vez que agame se volverá
loco y echará por tierra todo el
desarrollo de su país podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]